hello everybody I'm Jesse Waters along
with judge Janine Pio Piers Morgan Dana
Perino and Greg Gutfeld 5 o' in New York
City and this is the
[Music]
five President Biden completely bombing
in his first news conference since SAS
carried out their barbaric Terror
attacks against Israel the president's
sounding out of breath and could barely
muster up the energy to give Israel a
passionate defense the big news right
now is that Israel has reportedly agreed
to delay their invasion of Gaza so that
the US can Rush missile defenses to the
region to protect US troops there but
Biden says it wasn't me have you sought
assurances from him that he will hold
off on a ground Invasion into Gaza until
the safe relief release of the hostages
can be assured no what I have indicated
to him is that if that's possible to get
these folks out safely that's what he
should do it's their decision but I did
not demand it I pointed out to him if
it's real it should be done obviously
they're in Jeopardy the question is
whether or not there's any way of
getting them out and if we get them out
we should get them out Biden also
playing the both sides card the
president lecturing Israel a country
whose men and women and children were
just brutally butchered by
terrorists Israelis and Palestinians
equally deserve to live Side by side in
safety dignity and peace there's no
going back to the status quo as it stood
on October the 6 there has to be a
vision of what comes next and in our
view it has to be a two-state solution
and one more word on this I continue to
be alarmed about extremist settlers
attacking Palestinians in the West Bank
that uh pouring gasoline on fire is what
it's like they have to be held
accountable and has to stop now
and after letting Iran proxies attack US
troops 14 times the president is issuing
this timid little warning to tan my
warning to the Ayatollah was that if
they continue to move against those
troops we will respond and he should be
prepared all right judge Janine how do
you think the commander-in-chief
projected himself today in the Rose
Garden one word weak if they can we've
had 14 separate assaults 24 uh uh
military people injured a contractor
died of a heart attack and this guy says
if you continue to do that we're going
to get upset with you you shoot at an
American serviceman will'll come after
you in a tank it should be that simple
no one is buying what he's saying he's
not threatening anybody and you know
this whole idea and and there we've got
to recognize that to get in all the
missile defense systems they do need
time because those defense systems are
going to be over Iraq and Syria and
Jordan Saudi Arabia the UAE we've got
troops all over the world and so now
we've got to bring in the troops to or
the systems to protect them but Obama he
he he just contradicts himself last week
he said you know what he said I have uh
convinced the Egyptian officials to open
the Rafa border we can't even get
Americans out of the Rafa gate okay and
and right now he's telling or they're
telling Americans in Palestine and in
Lebanon and in Israel to come back to
the United States so he's got no power
he doesn't he doesn't in any way signal
power then you've got Nancy Pelosi she
comes out and says we don't want revenge
we want Justice well what should we do
Nancy should we put it on the Civil
calendar or the criminal calendar I know
in the Civil calendar is's a little bit
of a backlog I mean This Is War you put
on your big girl pants and you
understand that you fight the enemy
there will be civilian casualties Hamas
is waiting for us to go into the
territory this is a kind of war that no
one has ever waged fua moso are not like
this this is something that we've got
buildings above ground we've got fights
on ground and fights below the ground
and what we know right now is that Hamas
is putting the Palestinians out there as
pawns because just as they said the
hostage said oh it's air condition in
the tunnels they have doctors Medics
it's clean we had food we have fuel they
don't have hospitals in Palestine
because Hamas won't give them the fuel
that they obviously have so this is all
a PR War but in addition to that it's a
real war and Biden better get in there
and start fting it what do you think of
the president
today well he doesn't instill a lot of
confidence let's let's put it politely
uh I completely concur with view the
commander-in-chief of the United States
in situations like this when a bunch of
Americans by the way were also killed on
October the 7th um they've already been
actually killed in a proxy Way by Iran I
mean Iran are funding Hamas it was
clearly a massive operation they put on
lots of reports coming out now about
lots of training of Hamas uh terrorists
by Iran potentially in Iran as well so
Iran has already killed American
civilians on October the 7th and you
look at Joe Biden and you look at
somebody and you think is this a guy
that's actually going to go through on
what he's saying if you're Iran if
you're Putin if you're any of these
adversaries right now I think ever since
he did that ridiculous overnight pull
out in Afghanistan he lost all authority
with these adversaries and I think they
all fancy their chances uh that he will
not carry through on his word and I
think that's a a dangerous moment for
America a dangerous moment moment for
Israel uh and a dangerous moment for the
world so it's not good to see Joe Biden
exude that complete lack of confidence
or a belief that you think he's going to
carry out what he says he's going to
carry out because so far he
hasn't the IDF is itching to go in and
they can't like this delay at all it was
interesting because let me point out I
will no I will start with Kirby Kirby
said yesterday that a ceasefire would
only help a ma
okay but then how is that not the same
thing as a humanitarian pause as Pelosi
is calling it or delaying the ground war
to me then that is just helping Hamas so
I think Kirby is Right Kirby is a
military guy Kirby knows but Kirby is
also in a situation where you have an
Administration who is publicly and then
behind the scenes and also in the media
telling Israel to slow down and Israel
you better be you better take care of
the people there and you better think
ahead you better be and meanwhile
they're still counting the Dead M
they're still trying to do burials
they're still grieving they know and
maybe it won't be tomorrow maybe they
need an element of surprise who knows
maybe the IDF isn't ready who I I don't
know all of those things but I do think
that the pressure that the
administration is putting on in these
ways feels a little gross to me uh the
one thing the president did today that I
thought was very good is he was asked
about the death toll in Gaza citing
Hamas statistics and he said I have no
confidence in the number that the
Palestinians are using good that is very
helpful very useful and guess what New
York Times you could take that one to
the bank they're still in the New York
Times today wondering maybe it's still
plausible that the Israelis Bond the
hospital is properous the last thing I
would say is I thought it was jarring
and horrific that today the leaders of
Hamas Hezbollah and the Palestinian
Jihad are all meeting in Beirut and
there's pool
coverage there's like I was going to say
the freaking word they're they're taking
they're they're in there like as if they
called him into the Oval Office take
pool coverage camera like they were
going to take questions like for ex how
is it that they are still alive if the
three of them are together in one place
how is it not that they are the state
sponsor of terrorism right now in Beirut
who are you for um and I would say the
same thing about qar the two weeks ago
the Four Seasons in Doha had to put out
a tweet that said we can confirm that
the leader of Hamas is not staying here
why would they say that because they
don't want to get bombed because there
are people who are saying why are we
saying that like Qatar is so great maybe
they are they're good Ally on some
things but in the meantime they're also
dribbling out any sort of information to
Hamas to help protect them and the fact
that those guys could actually have a
meeting with media coverage to me is a
really bad sign about where this is
going also not great street cred if
you're a Hamas terrorist staying at the
Four Seasons yeah exactly right um what
a mess it's a mess you know it's weird
and amazing the further away we get from
Trump 2020 the closer he gets to the
White House in 2024 everything that he's
done just looks better and better
between inflation uh home prices a hot
War a cold war a broken border decimated
cities it makes you dream of a strong
country whose only problem was an
intelligencia plagued by Mean Tweets and
crash jokes we lost Trump because the
media preferred peace of Mind Over
actual peace and now Joe's got to be
worried because there's a major wakeup
call going on in his party Jewish
Democrats woke up October 8th and found
that all their allies that they
supported now see them as part of the
problem now Jewish voters went against
Trump 3 to one how did that work out yep
and all those people that you supported
on the street and in social media and
GoFundMe now they're saying sorry Jews
we mean you too uh they think you're
white even if you don't you are now part
of the white patriarchy that seeks to
marginalize people of color so how did
that happen how did that happen well who
needs a race baiting industry when you
Excel the Jews didn't need it right and
ironically it's the it's the race
baiting industry that keeps you down
right if you label people a victim they
stay victims instead you should be
emulating Jews instead of trying to hate
them anyway my advice to Jewish
Democrats leave
y you're being held hostage by that
party come over here the water's warm
and it's safe okay hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else